now that vaccines are rolling off the
assembly lines
where are they off to or developed
economies are at the front of the line
some countries are starting to vaccinate
the super-rich or celebrities
like here in indonesia where the
government inoculated instagram
influences the world health organization
is calling foul it's not right
that younger healthier adults in rich
countries are vaccinated
before health workers and older people
in poorer countries it's a problem many
saw coming
so is it too late for equality in the
largest vaccine drive in world history
well check this out the news
organization vice has discovered the
wealthy
are paying big bucks for specially
organized vaccine holidays
at a time of travel bans they take a
luxury trip to
india or the emirates long enough to get
their two jabs
and fit in some sightseeing critics say
using their money to jump the cue ahead
of the more vulnerable
is unacceptable campaigner nick dearden
says research shows
many more people will die if the rich
get the vaccine
first instead of doing it fairly we'll
talk to
him in a moment first healthcare workers
in kenya fear for their lives
the vaccine hasn't arrived yet and
covert is taking out their colleagues
one by one
dokas mogore loves her job as clinical
officer
a big part of it though was to work
closely with covet 19 patients
then one day she got sick herself i
survived covered i went through a lot of
problems after i was infected i didn't
have a medical cover which could cover
my bills and i got so sick
i was supposed to go on oxygen my both
of my sons were infected too
it was very traumatizing she survived
nine of her colleagues did not and then
another shock
she had to pay the expensive hospital
bill from her own pocket
for over a month now she's been on
strike with her nurses and medical lab
officers
more than 30 000 health care workers
according to the unions
their demands include protective gear
health insurance and compensation for
families
in case of death if any of us is to die
from coronavirus today
their family is going to live in
destitution
and as if that is not enough then they
tell you if you do not go back to that
unsafe working
environment we are going to search you
indeed healthcare workers across kenya
have lost their jobs for participating
in strikes the government says
are illegal nobody is denying that you
should be getting your money you should
it's a legitimate right but we are also
saying
that uh when there is this situation in
the country
let's also face it together you know and
don't make it look like you are
blackmailing the government
at his weakest point as dawkers doesn't
feel protected by her employer she's
awaiting the covet 19 vaccine
kenya expects to receive the vaccine
through the kovacs facility
among other sources but experts say a 60
vaccination target is needed to achieve
herd immunity on the african continent
meanwhile wealthy nations have reserved
more than half of the vaccines
even though they're home to only 14
percent of the world's population
so there's kind of some selfishness to
say let us fast reserve enough for our
people
i think the issue here is that global
responsibility issue so you can reserve
as many as you want for your country
but what is your responsibility to
ensuring the world is safe
to be safe that's also doka's wish for
herself
and her colleagues how do you feel about
that that kenya and other african
countries get the vaccination later
yeah we feel like we are less human
we feel like we are not considered but
anyway better late than never at least
we are hopeful we are going to get the
vaccination
kenya's first tranche of 24 million
vaccine doses is expected to arrive next
month
dawkers now hopes the vaccine will
finally ensure her safety
well hopes are higher elsewhere leading
some to accuse countries of hoarding
we'll get to that in a moment firstly
though let's look at some of the numbers
because funnily enough
the welcoming and oh so tolerant
canadians are first in line having
secured
the most vaccines per capita the u.s as
we mentioned it's organized over seven
doses per head the eu at least four
india
one and a half indonesia just one per
person
and the kovac scheme as you can see
there to share out shots is
sadly struggling
nick didn't is director of global
justice now and joins us from
london nick you've been campaigning for
global economic justice for over
20 years where's the justice in this
case
well it's a really good question because
you know we're so impressed with the
scientific ingenuity that has brought us
these vaccines
but unfortunately most of the world are
locked out of access
to the immunization that we also
desperately need they've been hoarded by
by rich countries and the patents the
monopolies on these vaccines are held by
some absolutely enormous businesses um
for the next
20 years which just makes it so much
more difficult to produce the numbers
that we need
it it makes it so much more difficult
for those of us who don't want to get
the corona virus because
you know if you're going to immunize or
vaccinate
only half the world it's it's not going
to solve this problem is it
well that's exactly right i mean we're
already seeing at the moment mutant
strains of course one of them's come
from my own country but there's one from
now we believe from south africa one
from brazil the longer you allow this
virus to run
unchecked in other parts of the world
the more
mutant varieties of it will come back
and hound us
so i mean on the one hand it's just
simply unfair of course i mean nobody in
europe would consider
only vaccinating the richest part of
their population
and keeping the rest of us in lockdown
yet we're perfectly
happy to do that for on a global basis
or at least our governments are
and i believe that's you know not
ethical not right
but i mean even if you just look at it
purely selfishly unless we
reduce the fact of the the virus is
spread everywhere
it's going to come back and rebound on
us potentially in varieties which are
immune to the to the vaccine and we knew
there was going to be this injustice
that's why this kovacs
system was set up but what happened to
that
that's right and the kovac system uh has
bought vaccines
for um lower income countries um it will
begin
distributing those vaccines soon but it
hasn't got enough money to buy all the
vaccines it needs
and frankly even if it did have the
money that the vaccines just simply
don't exist at the moment so kovacs was
invented
for for a great reason um it was
understood that if we gave this vaccine
out
in proportion to those who need it the
most so fairly around the world at the
same time
that's the way you're going to save most
lives you're going to immunize those who
are most at risk
and it could save um millions of lives
compared
to um only allowing the rich um to
immunize their own populations first
so it's a great idea the problem is that
many rich countries like my own
um decided that they were going to jump
the queue and simply buy
um millions and millions of vaccines
themselves so that there wouldn't be
enough left
on the market why why didn't they line
up why
why can't the brits line up orderly like
the germans do
it's okay it's a good question um we've
we've seen that a lot over the last
few years um but absolutely i mean they
they
they just decided they wanted you know
they wanted to vaccinate the whole
british population
first and i think seemed pretty immune
to the to the questions of global
injustice
it's not that they haven't given any
money to kovacs they have they've given
quite a lot to kovacs actually
i think one of the problems with the
british government particularly is it
always stands behind
the pharmaceutical industry some of the
companies of which are based
here and and regularly puts the returns
that those companies make
before the needs of the of the
population globally so at the moment
britain has
nick if i can cut him we only have a few
seconds how do we solve this then
is it a a case of governments having to
take over those patents from private
pharma
precisely and let's bear in mind many of
these
vaccines have been produced with public
money some have been produced entirely
with public money
so the idea that you then privatize that
knowledge
um and allow those companies to to make
profit off it
in coming years is just completely wrong
this is a pandemic
it's about people's health not about
return to shareholders
so the government should keep the
patents share the technology and help
countries around the world produce the
manufacturing capability
so that they can produce the amount
necessary to end this virus
nick didn't global justice now thank you
very much
it's a pleasure and it's that part of
the show where our science correspondent
derek williams takes the reigns and
answers your questions on the
coronavirus
what makes the new uk variant of the
coronavirus
more contagious viruses evolve over time
collecting
genetic changes called mutations
most of these changes don't make them
more effective in some way than their
forebears but
every once in a while through sheer
chance a variant
like the one discovered in britain will
acquire changes
that give it advantages in this case
they appear
to have made it more transmissible so
it's
able to infect more people to find out
exactly what's going on
at the molecular level scientists first
had to look at exactly where changes
occurred
in the variant's genome that made it
different from
earlier versions of source code 2. then
they had to try to figure out
how those genetic changes translated
into changes
in variant protein structures that could
explain
why people who get it are more
contagious
to enter cells sars cove cove2 uses a
structure called the spike protein
those are those bits that stick out all
over the surface of a coronavirus and
that's what it uses
to latch onto specific receptors
on a cell's surface as it seeks to break
in to make more of itself
in the new variant investigators
discovered
17 quite recent mutations and
eight of them affect the spike they
change its molecular shape in different
ways and it's likely that at least some
of those changes
make the variant better at latching on
to receptors
if the spike fits the receptor more
snugly the hypothesis goes it's probably
better
at infecting the cell possibly a lot
better for reasons that are less
clear some of the mutations might also
drive up viral loads in the throats
and noses of people who are infected so
so when they speak or cough they spread
more of the virus
to others those two aspects the experts
say
likely explain at least to some extent
why the new variant is more
transmissible